the merkel era is drawing to a close and
after 16 years in government angela
merkel will finally get a long awaited
rest
monday
number
at the end of september germany voted
this is dw news and these are our top
stories germany's center-left social
democrats say they have a mandate to
govern after winning a narrow victory in
the country's parliamentary elections
the sbd was elected the strongest party
with 25 percent
so soon it's juice to angela merkel and
hello to new chancellor
not so fast
as with most things in germany there can
be a long process before a new
chancellor is elected and this time it's
as much about the front runners for the
chancellery as it is about the king
makers from possible coalition parties
so who will be the next chancellor and
what happens to germany after merkel
[Music]
for merkel to leave the stage entirely
there first needs to be a new government
so what does happen to merkel and the
outgoing parliament in the meantime some
of the most important answers are in
here
according to germany's grund gazettes or
constitution the bundestag germany's
parliament must convene for its first
session no later than 30 days after the
election
the previous members of parliament
including merkel remain in the bundestag
until the first session
that also marks the end of the
chancellor's term in office but even
then merkel won't be clocking out of the
chancellery straight away at the request
of the german president currently frank
falter steinmeier the outgoing
chancellor is obliged to continue
government affairs until their successor
is elected
caretaker governments generally don't
make any far-reaching decisions
but the coming weeks will be dominated
by parties negotiating a new coalition
government but the clock is ticking
[Music]
so who will be mackel's successor isn't
that what germans just voted for
nope
the german chancellor isn't directly
elected by the people voters vote for
parties who will then be represented in
the new bundestag a stable government
will require the support of a
parliamentary majority
usually the new chancellor is the
candidate from the strongest party but
that isn't always the case
this time the choice could be between
the spd's olaf schultz and maybe even
the cdu's army lashed
that decision ultimately lies in the
hands of two parties that will be
coalition king makers the climate
friendly greens and the business focused
fdp
but how is a coalition formed
first it all kicks off with zombie
hunger
probing talks between parties only if
the chemistry is right will some parties
go into coalition
or coalition talks two coalitions look
most likely one option is the traffic
light coalition with red for the social
democrats who got the most votes yellow
for the business friendly free democrats
and green for well the greens
while the sbd and greens could get along
quite harmoniously getting the free
democrats on board could be trickier the
fdp opposes the sbd and greens plans to
tax the wealthier and wants to stick to
germany's strict balanced budget rules
which brings us to the second option a
conservative-led coalition also with the
greens and fdp
it's known as a jamaica coalition due to
the party's colours
it's no secret that the fdp would much
rather be in a jamaica coalition than a
traffic light combo in a jamaica
scenario it's the greens who would be
harder to convince particularly when it
comes to meeting germany's climate goals
the greens also want to see more public
spending than the cdu csu and fdp
but on the sidelines bilateral talks
between the greens and fdp have already
started
ultimately it's these king makers who
will influence who becomes mackel's
successor
[Music]
so forming a coalition will require a
lot of compromise and every party will
be fighting for their own interests but
what happens when talks collapse well
that's exactly what happened in 2017
after the last federal election
fdp leader christian lindner left talks
with the conservatives and greens
because he wasn't satisfied with the
compromise on the table
after almost six months of touring and
throwing politics in germany were at a
near standstill and after all that
germany still ended up with another
grand coalition with the conservatives
and spd the same as in the previous term
that was the last thing many voters
wanted then and now
if talks really hit a wall a minority
government is possible but that's always
been avoided in the interest of
stability
and if there's one thing germany loves
it's stability the absolute last resort
would be fresh elections
but that's highly unlikely
and there you have it there could be
some long nights weeks if not months
ahead
the only thing we can be sure of it will
be a man sitting in the chancellery
if talks drag on and merkel stays in
office till mid-december she'll become
germany's longest-serving chancellor
and when she does leave it will mark the
end of an era and the beginning of a new
one most likely with more parties
represented in government and that means
even more negotiations and compromise in
german politics in the future
[Music]
you